there's been a lot of talk recently
about bitcoin miners and their
relationship to the energy grid now one
of the things that most people don't
understand is that energy grids
sometimes they have extra energy and
other times they don't have enough
energy and so naturally that volatility
between how much energy is actually
available and how much demand there is
for the energy ends up creating problems
this is where you see things like
rolling blackouts in certain states now
the bitcoin miners they have an
advantage they actually can take on as
much energy as the grid will provide and
they also can shut off in pretty much a
moment's notice and return energy back
to the grid what this allows for is more
stabilization of an energy grid if there
is surplus energy then the bitcoin
miners take it up and they go mine
bitcoin but if all of a sudden there's
an increase in demand and there needs to
be more energy put into the grid the
bitcoin miners simply shut off and they
return that energy right back to the
grid here's a recent excerpt from an
interview on fox business where susan
lee went and talked to riot blockchain
one of the largest miners in north
america about this exact issue
term mining could strain the already
shaky grid susan how can they help
stabilize the state power grid well i
can tell you that the texas power system
is pretty tricky because it requires
really a perfect balance of supply and
demand and you saw that play out in
those 2021 winter rolling blackouts when
homes couldn't get heat so this time
around in this record-breaking heat wave
texas wants to make sure that the air
conditioners continue to cool they're
turning to a new source and that is
cryptocurrency mining and bitcoin miners
and how exactly are you helping out the
texas power grid so riot made
significant investment and made
significant commitments in the power
grid here and that has driven more
generation and helped stabilize the grid
but with that energy we secured we have
the unique property of being flexible
enough to provide that power back to the
grid when it is in high demand right so
basically you power up when there's
excess capacity and you power down when
there's a lot of usage and the state
needs more electricity for the in order
to cool the homes across this uh the
state exactly and that's very unique to
bitcoin mining not most most large
energy loads cannot just shut on and off
you know throughout the day we have the
flexibility because bitcoin blocks come
10 minutes apart and that's as much work
as we're doing yeah and also stu you
know they've uh they've purchased their
electricity and their power usage on a
10-year contractual basis already
now it's great to see this aspect of
bitcoin mining getting much more
attention plenty of people are yelling
and screaming they're critiquing bitcoin
mining they're saying it consumes too
much energy the truth is on the ground
bitcoin miners are helping to stabilize
energy grids and they provide for better
planning for many of these energy
companies ultimately bitcoin mining is
improving american infrastructure it's
not going anywhere and in fact my guess
is that many energy grids around the
country are going to start inviting
bitcoin miners there because they
understand the benefits and it solves
one of their most pressing problems hey
you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time